throughout my life as a young person I
used to look at my parents
I used to literally think oh my god I'm
so screwed because my parents were five
foot tall both of them
right and they didn't really have any
the physicality they didn't have the
physical you know attributes that our
society you know deems you know
pleasurable or and but I always had a
lot of great self-esteem issues because
of that but now in retrospect when I
look at my life I don't think that I
would have survived especially in the
business that I'm in in terms of
creating the kind of personality that I
have you mean because all those life
experiences that I have drove me to
become Who I am today
right and when I look in the mirror now
I wouldn't trade it for the world
I really wouldn't I love everything
about myself the way I look I love you
know I sometimes I look in the mirror I
start laughing at myself I look at
myself and I start laughing because I
just didn't why what look at you look at
you I say to myself look at how [ __ ]
up and weird you look right but that's I
say it in a good way you know I say it
in a way where I honestly I feel ashamed
that I wanted to change now I look like
an [ __ ] about the bone stretcher but
the truth of the matter is so if I have
you know I always thought like you know
I want to breed with a six foot three
you know me lady so that my kids had a
shot but I used to think that as in my
early 20s but now I believe that I don't
really care we don't short people live
longer anyways is that true
this is true this is true yeah there we
go yeah so I mean to take it back to
that longevity thing like being tall
places more stresses on the body your
heart has to pump you know to get the
blood up higher and you need higher
calories to maintain all that body mass
and all that sort of stuff so yeah being
tall it can be more of a challenge is
that is that why like people with
gigantism they die early I again not an
expert but maybe sure why not look Andre
the Giant he died early right yeah I
mean at that point you were a stretch
biology to its limits I think and you
know there's a reason why we're not
taller than we are so when you try to
sort of scale everything up it becomes
everything gets more stressed your bones
have more you know weight on them and
your muscles have to move you know
everything just gets more challenging I
guess you know you Derek I am about five
nine oh that's nice I mean it's not bad
I was kind of like shorter than almost
all of my class growing up yeah so it's
so like I'm kind of somebody like I
sympathize when you're saying like you
know I want to you know happy would you
trade your would you trade physical
attributes with your mind I don't think
so no I exactly know exactly yeah I'm
delighted with sort of where I've ended
up so yeah yeah we would not trade for a
few inches cuz I see doofy good-looking
tall white dudes all the time like I go
to a show man you're [ __ ] funny made
and they they walk around they're like
this is gigantic no personality no they
just have no just nothing about them
that I would deem like you know like
somebody that I wanna hang out with you
know it's like I prefer dudes like you
you know I want to say that I honestly
you're gonna ask him about the dick
bones no I'm not gonna ask him what we
want yeah I asked him a question okay uh
Derek